the Joe Rogan experience that was a
toughest part about the real long dives
that we did like every time stuff went
into that 9 10 hour range it's like
you're not eating anything right right
you come out and you're Haggard no I can
imagine man that's got to be [ __ ]
hard just when I do the UFC and I don't
really eat for like six or seven hours
it's hard it [ __ ] with you yeah your
your brain is just let your brains like
hey man this is not working well we need
some extra stuff some yes and what's
missing and she eat something
occasionally I'll get a hot dog or
something when I'm doing those but
that's just that that's just sitting
there talking yeah which you know what's
incredible how much burns off energy is
playing chess they did these uh they
have these world-class chess players in
these World Championship events and they
found out they were burning thousands of
calories just sitting there playing
chess because they were all losing
weight and they're trying to figure out
why these guys losing weight like what's
happening over the course of this
tournament you know just leaner but
their brain is firing Leath at 6,000
calories Robert Sapolsky our guy the
Stanford professor who we've had on the
podcast who studies stress in primates
at Stanford University says that a chess
player can burn up to 6,000 calories a
day while playing in a tournament three
times what an average person consumes in
a day yeah so they've they've figured
this out
fairly recently because of a lot of
these guys are losing [ __ ] loads of
weight that's why yeah your brain I
wonder like I don't think commentary
burns off anything near what a chess
player burns up but I wonder what it
does you you are thinking all day while
you're watching the fights I wonder how
much I'm burning cuz do when I get out
of there I eat like a [ __ ] wolf could
you take your whoop strap yeah yes I do
but it's your heart rate heart rate
isn't going up
yeah well also the whoop strap is
measuring yeah it's measuring your heart
rate and it's also I mean it's based on
your activity yeah I don't I don't think
it's gonna know like mental like because
I don't think their heart rate is jacked
if they're they're burning 6,000
calories a day just sitting yeah that's
gonna get
measure calories burned off of your
physical act yes right now additional
thing well that's also like different
exercises that are physically taxing and
also mentally taxing yeah they have to
be consuming more calories oh yeah
like like I was saying about the dives
mm-hmm like I've done dives that are six
to 12 hours long and you get out of the
water and you like I'm sitting there I'm
think like I'm using my brain a lot yeah
but it's also cold [ __ ] and I've come
out of the water a couple times and lost
eight plus pounds Wow
in the water in the water so that's nuts
yeah where is it going out so I'll
becoming a part of the ocean I guess I
don't know right minam yeah you're
pissing out a lot of liquid losing water
to the ocean while you're in the water
oh yeah
you could get dehydrated while immersed
in water yep
this is that polar that company that
polar strapped seems like it's a popular
one too they tracked a chess champion 21
years old in October he burned 560
calories in two hours of sitting and
playing chess loses about the same
amount as Roger Federer would burn in an
hour of singles tennis really whines
that's an hour of working I've done I
that's about what I do like an hour of
an elliptical is about 560 600 but I
feel like Federer just hopping around
all that plyos yeah that's true he's
hyper efficient right like Bernard
Hopkins when used to box yeah you know
it was super efficient yeah
elevate sustained elevated blood
pressure don't wonder if chess is the
pinnacle of things that you do that
aren't physical in terms of movement but
are incredibly calorie taxing I wonder
if that's the number me that's a very
complex game oh my god I would die and
maybe like go brain surgery go barely
moving but you're like concentrating so
hard for hours and hours at time yeah
yeah well there's certain things you do
that after it's over you're just [ __ ]
exhausted and starving to death like
when I do two shows a night after it's
over I'm so
hungry and that has to be something like
due to our 10 hour 15 minute sets
because you're thinking and you're
managing it while you're doing it is a
giant audience there you got to be
[ __ ] on like a yeah that's uh but I
think that UFC makes me more hungry but
it's also like six hours seven hours in
a day and you're probably moving around
a lot yeah
[Applause]